let's say I've been researching some
stocks to potentially invest in and I
feel pretty good at my ability to
predict how good company is going to do
relative to people's expectations or the
markets expectations and in particular I
focus on companies a and B and in the
case of Company A I think it's going to
do a lot worse than the market expects
it to do so I'm tempted I'm tempted to
short it and in the case of Company B I
think it's going to do much better than
the market expects so I'm tempted to buy
it or go long but there's one thing
about this process it gets me a little
bit uncomfortable I have confidence in
my ability to to pick out companies that
are going to outperform the market are
going to underperform the market but I
have no confidence in my ability to
predict the market so in general you
know let me draw a little chart of the
market this is the market price maybe
this is the S&P 500 or the Nasdaq and
I've just found that it's pretty as good
as random as opposed to me trying to
pick out bottoms of the markets or tops
of the markets and all of the rest and
so my fear is what happens if I buy
Company B based on my sound research and
then the market goes down then Company B
will probably still go down maybe it
won't go down as much as the market but
it'll still go down and I'll lose money
or what if i short company a and the
market goes up maybe it won't go
maybe company won't go a won't go up as
much as the market but I'll still lose
money on my short position which is
essentially a a bet that the stock is
going to go down so how can I is there
some arrangement I can do some
combination of buying Company B and
selling company or shorting company a
that will essentially hedge out a lot of
this market risk and as you can imagine
there is and I won't go into all of the
statistics of it in beta and how you can
really try to statistically hedge out
the market risk but the general idea is
if you really think this is going to
outperform the market or definitely
outperform Company A and if you think a
is going to underperform the market or
definitely underperform relative to
Company B you can go you can buy a
similar amount of B as you will short
Company A so in this case let's just do
one share you can obviously do multiples
of this you buy
one let me write it over here so we can
look at so you buy one share of Company
B one share and you sell or you short
one share of company a you borrow the
share you sell it you'll have to buy it
in a future date
so you short you short that shouldn't
say one shared you short two shares you
short two shares of Company A and the
reason why I'm saying two shares of
company instead of one share is because
a is only five dollars per share and B
is ten dollars per share so I want to do
roughly the same amount and once again
you can do fancier statistics on it to
tweak it so you can see how much they
actually move with the market but we're
not going to worry about that right here
so for simplicity for simplicity what
we've done here is we've taken a long
position let me write it over here we've
taken a long position long position in B
and we have a ten dollar long position
and we've taken a short position short
position in a and it is also a ten
dollar short position once again because
a is five dollars per share so we took
two shares of a it makes the same dollar
amount now let's think about and maybe
I'll save this for the next video I want
you to think about what happens if the
market moves up or down but B
outperforms a or a outperforms B